pas quand donc un plan de réouverture de
nos frontières chez nous on reçoit ce
soir christiane germain qui est
coprésidente de jaar germain hôtel
kirsten germé bonsoir bassorah sefilian
alors dites-nous est-ce que la relance
de vos activités et la reprise aussi
dans les villes passe par la réouverture
de la frontière
je vous dirais que la relance des
activités en région est très domestique
alors on n'a pas vraiment en notant qu'
on puisse circuler entre les provinces
je pense qu'on va être capable de
réaliser de bonnes affaires
par contre vous avez fait raison de
mentionner que la relance dans les
milieux urbains à haute densité je pense
à montréal france à toronto
ça va falloir que les frontières ouvre
afin qu'on puisse penser à faire de
bonnes affaires
oui parce que la photo de votre taux
d'occupation tourne autour de quoi en ce
moment je dirais que du 1er janvier de
cette année aller jusqu'au 30 mai nous
sommes à travers le canada no 18 hôtels
sommes à 18 % 18 % et généralement je
sais pas si vous êtes à 100% mais votre
taux tourne à combien généralement je
vous dirais dépendamment des mots mal
c'est entre soixante et soixante dix
pour ça alors à 18% ce gain évident à
monsieur fillion qu'on peut pas on ne
pourra pas continuer comme ça comme vous
savez encore bien bien longtemps mais le
jeu la nouvelle de la france est une
bonne nouvelle même si ça ne se passe
pas encore au canada j'ai l'impression
que ça va mettre un peu de pression sur
sur des pays comme le canada pour un
moment donné laissez tomber certaines
certaines règles
à l'entrée du canada et puis
éventuellement j'ose espérer que d'ici
quelques semaines le canada va ouvrir
ses frontières surtout si la vaccination
continue sur le même au même rythme que
qu'on le voit depuis quelques semaines
alors vous voyez ça comment les
prochaines semaines le séjour à l'hôtel
de trois jours la quarantaine
harry ouverture de la frontière si vous
avez un calendrier idéal dans votre
esprit c'est lequel je vous dirais que
la première étape c'est de s'assurer que
là c'est fluide entre les provinces
c'est la première étape était 1 heure
viennent d'ouvrir
j'espère que l'ontario ouvrir très très
très bientôt
et j'ose espérer que alami début juillet
on veut laisser tomber les trois jours
et là la quarantaine au canada pour
pouvoir ouvrir les frontières où
j'espère débuts avec donc la permission
aux personnes qui sont entièrement
vacciner c'est à dire de faciliter les
choses pour les personnes qui ont leurs
deux doses qu'ils ont entièrement raison
quand comme comme terre-neuve la fête de
cette semaine les personnes entièrement
vaccinées peuvent aller à terre-neuve et
ceux qui ont un vaccin on leur demande
de passer un test et ceux qui n'ont
absolument rien quarantaine obligatoires
quelles sont les conséquences pour votre
saison estivale si les frontières ne
trouve pas avant l'automne avant
septembre octobre
écoutez ce sera écouté j'ai j'ai
l'impression que je me répète le mais ça
va continuer d difficile surtout pour
les grands centres toronto montréal on
s'en sort bien à charlevoix on s'en sort
assez bien dans des plus petits marchés
maintenant que saint jean est ouvert ça
va sûrement nous aider un petit peu mais
pour les grands centres absolument vous
devrez frontières et puis permettent aux
gens de circuler librement c'est la
seule et unique façon d'arriver à
repartir quand vous allez repartir
justement on a parlé cette semaine le
coût des services hôteliers sera en
forte hausse pourquoi expliquez-nous ce
qui se passe je voudrais sefilian on en
a parlé aussi on a parlé beaucoup de la
pénurie d'emplois et une réelle était
très très importante actuellement
probablement plus dans la restauration
que dans l'hôtellerie mais je vous
dirais la minute que l'hôtellerie va
repartir comme on souhaite
il va y avoir aussi une pénurie de
personnel ces pénuries l'a7
françois que les salaires actuellement
c'est très difficile de recruter donc
les salaires augmentent et les salaires
augmentent 1 le coût des denrées
augmentant je pense à la restauration
je peux pas imaginer qu'on va pouvoir
conserver les mêmes prix que nous avions
en 2019 alors j'ai l'impression qu'il va
y avoir une augmentation des prix pour
une augmentation juste je parle pas
d'une augmentation pour profiter d'une
situation mais je parle vraiment comme
vous le savez les marges de profit sont
surtout dans la restauration pour un
très mince alors si on veut un moment
donné faire ce qu'on devrait faire pour
rester en france qu'il va falloir vous
pensez que les visiteurs vont accepter
ça je pense que oui moi je pense que
pour l'instant je pense que les
consommateurs s'y sent qu'on abuse deux
hommes vont probablement réagir très
négativement mais le consommateur est
intelligent mc caw jeu lille est
intelligente elle voit que dans les
épiceries des la nourriture augmente on
parle beaucoup justement de
l'augmentation des salaires dans la
restauration et dans l'hôtellerie dans
les industries de services
alors je pense que si on veut rester en
affaires si les restaurants ce pour tout
dire est d'ouvrir des restaurants effet
s'assurer que les conditions gagnantes
sont là pour justement qu'on continue à
faire des affaires
parce que bon la dernière année j'ai pas
besoin de vous le répéter a été
extrêmement difficile
alors si on veut se rester en affaires
va falloir le profit c'est le neuf la
guerre vous savez très bien
je pense que l'augmentation des prix et
tu as peu près inévitable
merci beaucoup pour ses explications
et cette analyse de votre part de votre
point de vue bien sûr très clair merci
que saint germain merci beaucoup
monsieur fillion pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit